when dance style first become a big deal
in your life because I know you love now
this right now thank you
you know I grew up in New York and I
think that New York has that kind of
influence on you you know you walk down
the street and you know when I was a kid
growing up it was really I would see
Andy Warhol can't no walking down the
street I would you know and I and I
always appreciated style I would look at
like GQ magazine and dream about being
on the cover one day and I was with Tom
Hanks and Will Smith years later but
when I was a kid kid I would sell stolen
polo shirts on 14th Street on a box yes
and I would carry the box around on 14th
Street I'm dreaming about you know one
day I'm gonna be on the cover of GQ and
one day I can afford to actually wear
these clothes and I don't know how it's
all gonna work but I know I can do it
but the meantime I'm selling you stolen
shirts subscribe to my channel subscribe
to my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going